a band performs in an almost deserted
theme park this is Disneyland normally
one of Hong Kong's most popular tourist
attractions but there are no queues for
the rides and other attractions today on
average 18,000 people visit each day
many of them from mainland China but the
unrest that began on June the 9th has
made it harder for Hong Kong to sell
itself
as a fun destination the neighborhood of
Mong Kok has seen some of the worst
violence the Bravo clothes boutique on
Prince Edward Road regularly has to
close early but always opens the
following morning only the graffiti
hinting at what had happened a few hours
earlier the shop faces Mong Kok police
station a frequent target for
demonstrators since mid-june business
has fallen by 80%
yet the solitary sales assistant says
she supports the protests because she
says they want what she wants of course
freedom freedom since I'm not the boss
and just an employee
I think freedom is more important but my
boss would think business is more
important at the nearby noodle xi
restaurant customers are still coming
but business is 30% down on a month ago
and while the owner remains confident
Hong Kong's economy will recover he's
still worried it's hard to sustain the
business hard to pay the rent and the
staff in more prosperous districts sales
staff outnumber customers in some luxury
boutiques visitors from the Chinese
mainland are still arriving but they're
spending less time here and less money
some appear indifferent to the unrest
once I got here it seemed fine it's not
as horrible as I imagined even before
the protests began on June the 9th it
had not been a good year for Hong Kong's
economy it's been feeling the effects of
the trade war between China and the
United States as well as the slowdown in
China's economy and all of that argue
some economists could be an
to push Hongkong into recession this is
a city where divisions in society are
deepening and no matter how it all ends
many people on both sides agree on one
thing
Hong Kong is unlikely to be the same
again Adrian Brown al-jazeera Hong Kong